wer wird dann jetzt zuerst geimpft die
ständige impfkommission die hat ein
papier erarbeitet so einen sogenannten
impfplan aus dem hervorgeht wie geimpft
werden sollen welcher reihenfolge auch
geimpft werden soll und daraus geht
hervor dass natürlich diejenigen die
besonders alt sind die über 80-jährigen
in der ersten gruppe sind das ist
kategorisiert in insgesamt sechs gruppen
und es beginnt mit den ältesten in der
zweiten gruppe sind dann diejenigen über
75 auch daran und es geht natürlich um
menschen auch mit vorerkrankungen da
gibt es dann auch unterschiede
aber man kann im prinzip sagen
diejenigen die am stärksten von einer
infektion betroffen wären und die
beispielsweise dann auch mutmaßlich bei
einer infektion sterben würden das sind
diejenigen die ganz ganz vorne dran sind
es gibt einen streitpunkt weil in der
gruppe 3 in der dritten phase unter
anderem auch insassen von
asylbewerberheimen und gefängnissen geld
wären aber polizisten beispielsweise
erst in der vierten gruppe vorgesehen
sind und da hat man gesagt es kann
eigentlich nicht sein einige
landesinnenminister haben sich da glaube
ich zu recht haben das kritisiert und
gesagt die polizisten müssten eigentlich
auch in der dritten gruppe dran sein
gibt auch kritik von den lehrerverbänden
die lehrer sind nämlich auch erst in der
vierten gruppe dran also da können die
länder dann noch selbst eine änderung
auch am impfplan vornehm aber
prinzipiell gibt es erstmal diesen
diesen im plan der ständigen
impfkommission und dann wird man jetzt
in diesen tagen sehen das hat sich jetzt
auch druck bei den innenministern der
länder wie sieht dieser impfplan
eigentlich aus und das wird spannend zu
sehen sein opfer noch veränderungen
bezüglich der vorgabe der ständigen
impfkommission geben wird
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren